ya no hay margen para dudas de Benjamin
le tenía ajo aseguró una cómoda mayoría
en el parlamento y se encamina a volver
a gobernar en Israel el recuento de
votos otorgan los escaños necesarios
para formar una coalición a su partido
licut y a sus aliados el sionismo
religioso de extrema derecha y los
partidos Ultra ortodoxos el dirigente de
73 años se tendrá la oportunidad de un
tercer ciclo como Primer Ministro hecho
sin precedentes en la historia del
Estado un síntoma de la derechización
del electorado israelí es que el
izquierdista se queda afuera del
parlamento por primera vez desde su
creación en 1992 Este era uno de los
pocos partidos sionistas en apoyar la
paz con los palestinos y denunciar la
ocupación israelí con este escenario
medios israelíes se reportaron que ya
iniciaron los diálogos informales entre
los partidos de la probable coalición
una vez que reciba el mandato del
presidente Isaac gersok netanía Ju
pretende formar rápido un ejecutivo para
cumplir su promesa de derrocar al
llamado gobierno del cambio que Le
entregó en 2021 en las charlas se
definirá el reparto de ministerios y los
lineamientos de un gobierno y la
incógnita Es zinetaníaco logrará moderar
algunas de las aspiraciones en más
radicales de sus socios que han
expresado deseos de una reforma judicial
para limitar a la Corte Suprema o
anexionar por completo los territorios
palestinos ocupados en cualquier caso
Israel se prepara para un escenario
incierto con el gobierno más radical
hacia la derecha Ultra nacionalista y
Ultra religioso en su historia